every time I come here I learn more
about Tampa
now last year I learned that there was a
strip club where the women were over 50
called mermaids
[Laughter]
and if you're wondering if I went
yes I went
Listen by the way if you go and you get
a boner something's wrong with you
it's like going to a museum you're like
oh look at that one
is that what it looks like after a while
okay
last year when I was here I also learned
that sometimes when you're on one side
of the street it's sunny and the other
side of the street it's raining
I was looking across the street like am
I having a flashback right now
why is it raining it's over there so
weird to see people in shorts on one
side and umbrellas in the other